Mike Pereira joining us here the NFL on
Fox rules analyst and former top zebra
and the National Football League here on
the program you know Mike I'm doing good
rich how are you thinking about my
superstitions
though you know do you have it did you
have one you know you know mine is mine
is my only one I really had is golf and
if I make my first putt then my putter
cover has to go in the exact same spot
for all 18 holes when I take it off so
but if I move it anywhere else I'm like
afraid I'm gonna miss a putt so that's
that's about the only one I could think
of not even when you were appreciate it
was there did was there an official that
was a superstitious all also you or any
of your colleagues I don't think they
would admit it if they were I mean you
know we all had to think you'd wear your
same undershirt if you were in a good
streak or something like that but that
almost superstition is a part of sports
and practically everyday life but I
don't think I really had a really legit
superstition when I was officiating
which is maybe why I wasn't very good
all right Mike let's get to what Troy
Vincent saying I heard at the combine
that the catch rule is gonna basically
be two feet down and a football Act
we're gonna get the football Act back
again what are you hearing well I'm
hearing the same thing which I think is
a good thing I talked to Roger Goodell a
couple of weeks ago who had just come
from the from the combine and you know I
asked him to kind of explain to me what
he saw this coming too and he just he
said to me the same thing that has been
everybody's been saying they're
basically going to take the going to the
ground out of the roof which is good the
rule needs to be traded the treated the
same whether it's a receiver is upright
or whether he's going to the ground make
it the three-step process and it is
control two feet and then whatever it
looks like you just said it whatever it
looks like then it should be and so
you've got that third element there
which is still going to be there call it
a football move call it time call and
what I call it whatever you want to call
it the key component which I haven't
heard yet
is I think replay needs to be involved
and can be involved with can
trol and two feet but after that I don't
think replay can be involved I think
it's purely judgement as to how long
this bake timeframe is and so that
really needs to be left out of it
because if they leave it in then really
all that's going to happen is the
controversy is going to go from the
ground to the time and and we're going
to look at plays that either get
overturned
you know because replay makes it look
like he's at the ball long enough at a
different speed so that's a key issue
coming out of it and I'm really anxious
to hear you know how that's gonna be you
know a part of the new rule well I think
we're gonna hint on that and I want to
put a pin in that part of our
conversation for a second cuz of
contrived instance said something about
replay to the Washington Post that
really jumped out at me but like I said
I want to put a pin in that for a second
Mike Pereira and get to the fact that
with the Calvin Johnson play under the
new rule touchdown the Jesse James
played under the new rule touchdown the
question is is because both of them
involved the end zone and crossing the
plane or being in the end zone already
the rule as it will be written what
would it make the Dez Bryant play would
that make that a catch fumble or a catch
and he's now a runner and just like a
runner a ground can't caused a fumble
will they turn the receiver into now a
runner with two feet down and the
undetermined football Act that we just
need to see when we see it yes so Dez
becomes a catch and down by contact
because once he controlled the ball in
air there was contact with the duplicity
defender so when he then goes to the
ground and reaches out which is this
kind of element of time thing then it
becomes catching down by contact and if
he wasn't touched and the ball comes out
when he hits the ground after doing
something then then it is gonna be a
catch and a fumble and I think that's
fine I mean you know the league always
is concerned about offense and they
don't necessarily like fumbles but you
know the onus is still gonna be on the
receivers to hold on to the ball but
every play that you've described
and I think this is key that you know
what does it look like what does it feel
like and let's go to Calvin Johnson
initially one official ruled it a
touchdown another one came over and kind
of sheepishly said you know incomplete
and of course it stayed incomplete what
they ruled Jesse James they ruled it a
touchdown on the field what did they
ruled Dez Bryant they ruled it a catch
so the officials looking at this play
felt that they had completed the process
and so you know to me that's the part
that you can't make reviewable let the
officials make their judgment call on
the field and leave it as is but I think
everybody even though the rules get
similar to me like that's all the way
back to 2001 I mean the Tuck play
everybody felt it should have been a
fumble and it looked and smelled and
tasted like a fumble but the rule made
it incomplete and that's the same thing
with des and the same thing with Calvin
and the same thing with Jesse James and
so let's let's bring the rule in to
really how it would know that you can
put some common sense back into the game
and who's been saying that who's been
saying that for years probably some guy
named I yeah yes the Rich Eisen show
thanks Mike so so but since I know you
have a photographic memory Mike what
about that that play between the
Patriots and Giants regular season game
Odell Beckham grabs it one in the end
zone and Malcom Butler just as he might
have gotten that second foot down slaps
the ball out how would that work in an
end zone play incomplete no no elements
of time and you know that looked like he
had both feet down and then the ball was
knocked out but it was almost
simultaneous if they just go back I go
back to really when I officiated and the
rule wasn't just complex here's what the
rule said back in 96 and 97 it just
basically said it is a catch if a
receiver gets control and two feet down
I said stop there and Bennett said if
there's any question in the mind of the
official then rule it incomplete the old
bang-bang
and all the rule that's all there who
said and we lived by that and there was
an issue of course there wasn't replay
either that's exactly and that's until
replay until replay so let's get to that
now let's remove the pin format as you
said that you hope that replay will not
be used to judge time and it looks like
it won't because as you know over the
last few months we were all wondering
certainly here on the show if with
Blandino now being a colleague of
viewers at Fox and Al River on coming in
if if replay started to be used
differently this year by the NFL in the
regular season and it was and they
changed it back for the playoffs best I
could tell and this quote kind of
confirms this Mike this is what Troy
Vincent told the the the Washington Post
will go back to the old replay standard
of reverse to call on the field
only when it's indisputable and I rich I
think they did that you know about
two-thirds of the way through the season
and they were consistent throughout that
last third and you know Jesse James
after Jesse James Jesse James James you
know you know that that was ridiculous
listen I think there's still the notion
here's how confusing it is I mean or at
least as can confusing it is gotten you
know there was significant discussion on
the back hurts play in the Super Bowl
the touchdown in the Super Bowl there
was significant discussion going on
during that review about reversing that
to an incomplete pass when you know many
of us including myself or sitting there
saying why did they even stop this to
look at it and it was this whole notion
of did he have the ball long enough to
become a runner did he have was he going
to the ground
you know the replay replay almost
reversed meant to an incomplete pass
which would have been a travesty as far
as I'm concerned so you know I think
that the notion of a strict standard of
it has to be so obvious that a mistake
that was had been made to overturn it
that certainly needs to be emphasized
with Al and his band of guys in New York
and let's not forget to now but as we
talked about replay and the catch
replay looks like it's gonna be involved
in ejections now too and not just the
Bron Kowski late hit you know or the
Evans hit on the sideline but you're
talking about normal ejections for
throwing punches and doing that kind of
stuff and so replay replay continues to
grow and you know although I'm still an
advocate to a degree I worry that it
goes really to an extent beyond its
usefulness
well I mean in terms of that though I
don't mind if replay shows uh you know
hey somebody throwing punches with each
other and and the refs either didn't
call didn't see it or or on you know in
the flow of a game just decided for
whatever reason to let it go and and
somebody who's removed from the emotions
of the game can come down and say that
that is it doesn't matter what the
emotions of the game are we shouldn't
have these types of plays I don't have a
problem with that I also you know I I do
believe though I do want to correct
myself
I think replay changed the way they were
viewing not after the Jesse James play
which I think if I'm not mistaken
Brockman was week 15 of the NFL season
when the Steelers and the Patriots
played each other it was after the
Calvin Benjamin play in week 16 in New
England where the Buffalo Bills had a
touchdown taken off the board with
something so ridiculous that that I
think I heard from members in the
competition committee pointing to that
play is saying that that was a watershed
moment of them coming in and saying to
our River ons crew guess what and the
art McNally Center were going back to
what was going on here in 2016 and prior
that the reverse to call only when it's
flat-out indisputable yeah and you know
I go back to I go back to Mike Patrick
who the first year and replay he said to
me and it got technical even halfway
through the first year in 1999 and he
said to me you know in order to in his
opinion that no the reverse a call and
replay you got to look at it the first
time and see it's wrong and if you have
to
go back it up frame by frame move it
back and move it forward and move it
back forward let it be and that's
probably the standard that you know
always should have been really heated to
you know right from the get-go but I
talked to Dean Blandino about this a lot
too and you know because he was the guy
that was supposed to be making the
decisions and he had made these
decisions you know in the past and he
even admitted that he sometimes got too
technical you know you did you kind of
lose track of what you're trying to do
you're not trying to make the call
that's not what you're trying to do
you're trying to really conclude that
the call on the field that was made was
right and not reverse it on a
possibility that it might be wrong and
and I and and look at I've said this
before and I know the league isn't happy
with some of the things that I have said
about our River on or the leak but he
was never intending to make these
decisions he really hadn't been making
these decisions in the past the
ownership gave the right to New York to
make these decisions they thought it was
going to be Dean bland female so then
our River on then gets thrown into this
and and had to make the decisions
there's some you know certainly some
adjustments that have to be made and you
have to go through some trial and error
I'm just I'm hopeful that after what
happened last year that they will
certainly stay with that stand well what
it needs to be the playoff certainly
proved that that they did get a ride I
thought the playoffs was perfect a
couple more quick hitters for you Mike
before I let you go here 15 yards for
defensive pass interference you think
that's going to work I don't think it'll
pass okay III know there's never been
any sentiment to that even though I was
a huge fan of you know making that
change because I think 40 yards or a
pass interference is is too punitive and
I think 10 yards for an offensive pass
interference is not very punitive I
don't I don't think there's consistency
in the rule and I think it's too much
pressure on the officials but let's
remember you know the competition
committee if a club proposes a rule like
that so
say that there is a New England Patriots
that proposed that rule it must go to
the ownership to vote on even if the
committee votes themselves all eight
against it and so I I have a suspicion
that that's the case I just I would love
it but I just don't think it really has
to be pretty and lastly what are you
doing with the veterans who are looking
for work and and and giving them a path
to become officials tell me about what
you're doing I mean yeah we started the
foundation actually my wife and I
started that a year ago and we have a
shortage of officials around the country
we have a bunch of veterans that are
having trouble getting back into their
communities and so we started this
foundation and we give scholarships to
veterans to become sports officials in
their communities all sports not just
football and we've been doing it for a
year now and we currently have given out
a hundred and three scholarships around
the country we have an ice hockey
official who's a veteran from Rochester
and New York it's been really kind of
unbelievable there's a need for
officials there's a need to help those
veterans that are struggling a bit and
I'm in New Orleans now met with the
Saints today and we're gonna partner
with the Saints and get some of these
vets out on their practice fields and
scrimmages and things like that Sean
Payton and I have communicated by text
he's at the competition committee
meeting now I'm going to the Falcons
tomorrow I want to get the NFL involved
in this project too it's it's been a
really wonderful endeavor that my wife
and I have taken on and there was an
article today that was an Associated
Press which kind of talked about one guy
my guy Hector trango that's severe case
of PTSD and who found officiating and it
seems to have turned his life around and
so I'm really I'm really enthused about
it and thank you for asking of course
appreciate that battlefields the number
two ball fields org battlefields two
ball fields org good for you Mike and
for your better half for doing this
well thank you it's a it's a labor it's
a labor of love I'm not a veteran I
didn't serve I was in the Vietnam era in
the lottery draft of the birthday draft
and I so I didn't serve but you know we
neglect so much you know for some things
with our veterans and and we don't give
them their due and I personally believe
that with what they go through when you
talk about courage and competence and
teamwork and focus and mission I believe
they could be great officials and so I
think it's a win-win for both them and
for officiating well done Mike travel
safe say hi to everybody
you got it thank you got it Mike Pereira
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience